[Musique]
du ski a tu veux ma photo
nous sommes une rumeur
parfum de déjà vu regardez par ici
un souvenir fugace nous sommes le secret
le mieux gardé de la galaxie embauché
moi il y a vingt ans vous avez effacé la
mémoire de mes parents mais pas la
mienne on n'embauche pas on recrute dans
ce cas je veux être recrutés je veux
connaître la vérité sur l'univers rock
au sud
bienvenue chez les men in black
les hommes en noir non ne commencez pas
j'essaie de faire bouger les choses
on a un problème à londres
[Musique]
un jour m bienvenue chez les mots des
blagues salées pack l'espace public
parce nous ferait équipe avec l'agent
rage à l'est le monde va pas sauver tout
seul je prends le voilà c'est très
coûteux devrait se trouver là bas dans
ce pays
la ruche et une espèces prédatrices
capable de prendre la forme d'un
n'importe qui même celle de nos agents
j'ai jamais vu ça
on sort la grosse artillerie et des
rétroviseurs je fais quoi avec je m'en
sers comme promise et méchant est en
train stade et entre ya une taupe chez
les men in black
la vue s'arrache parfois il faut écouter
son instinct
il faut je trompé j'ai cru qu'on était
arrivés et les gaz freddy ces partis h
[Musique]
vous savez pas à qui vous avez affaire
on protège la terre et tout ce qui s'y
trouve
sérieux c'était mortel nous sommes les
men in black
si je comprends bien tu veux connaissent
l arme la plus puissante de la galaxie
pour le second voisine puis sur le
bouton
augmenter un petit peu là